hello and welcome to ed talks with khan
academy i'm kristen decervo the chief
learning officer at khan academy and
today i am looking forward to talking to
dr ted co
who is with nwea one of our key partners
here he is the director of content
advocacy and design we're looking
forward to talking about math and math
learning today
before we get started i want to remind
you that khan academy is a non-profit
organization and relies on donations
from folks like you to help us continue
to be able to do our work so if you go
to khan academy.org donate you will find
a place where you can help keep us
supported and work in continuing our
work
so thank you for that i also want to
acknowledge our uh corporate supporters
who have come and and helped us work
through the covid19 crisis including att
general motors and fastly
if you would like to listen to
this conversation or any of our previous
conversations
you can wherever you get your podcasts
find the homeroom lasalle the podcast
and you'll be able to listen wherever
you uh prefer at the gym
uh for on your walks doing the dishes we
hope you enjoy it
so before we get uh without further ado
let me introduce dr tedco so he has over
25 years of experience as a teacher
professor department chair administrator
and a non-profit director basically
weaving together perspectives about
mathematics education
he has experience as a full-time high
school mathematics teacher community
college faculty member a mathematics
chair at two community colleges and an
assistant dean of the university level
and um i will say as someone who is a
graduate of arizona state university he
is a fellow sun devil as well welcome
thank you thank you glad to be here
we are glad to have you so
first of all tell us what your role is
specifically what do you do at nwea
this is this is an interesting question
right uh the uh the answer is the title
is director of content advocacy and
design for mathematics and the the
interesting side to it is is well i get
to advocate for content and and so i it
for many ways for me it's like this
dream world to be in where i get to kind
of uh imagine the kinds of things that
we want to work on how do we want to
grow how do we want to
move beyond a focus on assessment to
teaching and learning and getting into
the classroom you know and and getting
it so so it's it's envisioning these
kinds of things it's being able to work
with different states and districts and
get in there and roll up our sleeves and
get our our hands dirty trying to solve
some some pretty messy problems so uh
that's a lot that's a lot of what i get
to do and so to me it's just it's it's
great fun
that's fantastic how did you come to be
in this role what was your path that you
took to end up here
it's so it was so
bizarre it's a lot it's a crazy path
career path people you know and the
started out as a high school teacher uh
things were going well i loved high
school teaching highlight highlighted
the career right then i then i ended up
i ended up getting pulled over to one of
the community colleges and i actually
walked right in my first job in the
community college system was as a as a
chair at rio salado college in the
maricopa community college district so
it was like this this big this big sort
of leap uh i did i ended up switching
over to uh another community college in
the district scottsdale and uh and while
i was there i ended up being involved
deeply in the uh in the mathematics
around the whole community college
system and and kind of involved in the
articulation conversations around the
state and everything and somewhere
somewhere along that time
uh the park consortium came along and
you might remember this this was in the
early years of the common core and there
were the two major consortia park and
smarter balanced and and i was brought
on to this this the the park side of the
conversation arizona was uh
one of the governing states at the time
and i was brought in as one of the
higher ed content experts and so i was
dropped into this space all of a sudden
where i was i'd been a
college professor and high school
teacher and and now i was in this space
where it's like we want your input on
this multi-state assessment that's on
these new standards and so i'm like well
let's read the standards let's see what
this is about and and i got really
involved in it and so much in fact that
that eventually uh park park split off
of the the group that was running it
which was called achieve and achieve was
you know the ones for the american
diploma project help lead the common
core and all that and the next
generation science standards and so they
uh you know they hired me to be their
math director and so for the for for
the years prior to coming into this into
this space at nwea where i've been for
two years i was the director of
mathematics there and got to work all
around the country with great folks
everywhere and really get to see uh
how the how the the policies and worked
out and the difficulties that people
were encountering and trying to talk
through some of those things and getting
the chance to speak all over the country
it was it was great fun it's been it's
been great fun and it's been
one surprise after the other and here i
am today
fantastic that sounds great
so let's talk a little bit about
teaching and learning math um
historically
there's been all this discussion about
should i teach
should we teach procedural skills should
we teach conceptual understanding and
there's this almost these wars about
which one is more important than where
those is is that the right conversation
to be having
you know it it's it's it's it's a tale
as old as time at least as old as my
career has been right that there's this
there's always this tension in there and
and so you know i've had to sit back and
think to myself you know how
how would i describe
teaching and learning mathematics after
my 20 years of teaching and you know i
was like well how do i sum this up uh
and i it was somebody developed along
the way but it was just this idea that
look part of part of what we do in in in
mathematics is is we teach these ways of
doing
uh but and we want you to be able to do
those but we also we also want to make
sure that you're picking up ways of
thinking and i'll give you an example of
that in just a moment that go alongside
habits of thinking so you have these
ways of thinking sort of at a core that
are that are bolstered by these habits
of thinking that are then in turn really
sort of uh brought you know they come to
the table in certain ways through the
ways of doing that allow you to go on
and do something bigger with the
mathematics an example i use uh quite
frequently is with this idea of ways of
thinking and i can ask a room full of
adults this question and basically i say
something like hey you know
how many years was it from december 7th
1941 to december 7th 2014 that's how
long i've been using this question okay
so so december 7th 2014.
and and uh and
you know
by and large you ask this to a room full
of even adults right and people will sit
there and they start chewing on on an
answer and they start going oh what can
i do what can i do and then they go
through some mechanizations in their
head and they go they might think well
that's actually kind of a subtraction
problem but i don't really need to do
use subtraction to get it because in
this case i'm just trying to find this
additive comparison and this gap if you
will between the two numbers and there
are different ways to do it maybe i want
to go from 1941 to 2000 and cut it off
and then go from 2000 to 2014 or or
maybe i want to maybe i want to take the
whole thing it says starting in 1941 i
want to slide the whole thing back a
year and start in 1940. uh
either way all of these things are fair
but
but
but the majority of the folks i asked
that question they don't answer it with
the way of doing they don't do the 15
steps of setting up the algorithm
borrowing not giving back all that kind
of thing putting the one they don't do
that they they they bring ways of
thinking to bear
right and and i think yeah i think maybe
part part of what's part of why we uh
get into this mess is in the standards
we have the learning progressions
but and the learning progressions and
with the ways of doing
and so it looks like the way of doing is
the goal but the end the way of doing is
just one more thing it's just one more
piece
right
so yeah so so i really i really like to
emphasize this idea of ways of thinking
when regard with regards to uh ways of
thinking ways of doing habits and things
all of those things working together
because if you have just one the ways of
doing all you've got is a box of puzzle
pieces you know
yeah right
so my so i'm going to keep going with a
year example here to push on this so my
sister got married in 1997 and i have to
say somehow never made this connection
but she said to me one day if you want
to know how long we've been married just
take what current year it is and add
three because
1997 to 2003 and then i was like
oh yeah why did i not think of that
but so that's a way of doing it
so then that's one way is that how does
that relate them to ways of thinking and
so are there many different ways to do
it and the ways of thinking around it
yes the idea is that when i ask that
question there are so many different
ways you could approach it right you
could approach it with a way of doing
and no harm no foul you could approach
it with ways of thinking but if you all
you have is the way of doing and you
don't have those ways of thinking then
when you get when you get to somewhere
in real life it it doesn't it doesn't
illuminate and a place where this
happens is you can ask you can ask like
uh where where in real life
ask this to an adult where in real life
have you ever actually used division of
fractions
and i'll be surprised if you actually
get any valid answer back from anybody
right and why is that because if we
reflect back to it when we when we were
taught the the division of fractions
those of us who were of a certain age
right we were taught a way of doing and
it was connected it was totally
disconnected from ways of thinking
grounded in what does it mean to divide
so that so you just yes you were just
taught the procedure yeah yeah yeah and
so when you've got the procedure but you
have no place to hang it when it comes
and shows up in real life
right right that totally makes sense so
if i'm a teacher
how do i start thinking about
encouraging these ways of thinking
see that's that's the tricky part right
right
yeah right and so uh
one one really cool thing that happened
in the last couple years peter lillia de
hall came out with a book called
building thinking classrooms and i'm
like yes yes we're seeing this emphasis
shifting to thinking fantastic
because at the same time uh i we that my
colleagues and i at nwa have been trying
to work on this
this this idea of how can we get ways of
thinking
moving and talked about in classrooms in
ways that are non-threatening
right that feels safe to both teachers
and students because
there's awkwardness when we ask
ourselves thinking questions all of us
have to stop and think and with thinking
comes vulnerability
right uh so what we built we actually
built out some we actually built out
some things called these uh formative
conversation starters and the the role
of the formative conversation starters
is to basically
help shape how you might enter into some
of these kinds of conversations that are
designed to focus on ways of thinking
and then to
do it in such a way that you also know
what it is you're trying to listen for
at the same time
so we've got these bins these big ideas
to nurture sense making and then we've
got
clusters of questions that
unfold as you ask them and might lead
the moments of cognitive dissonance or
might leave the ah-has or might lead to
places where you kind of step back and
go i really do need to think more deeply
about that
so so there are different there are
different options of to do it you can
put in classroom routines you can build
uh
tools you know like we've like we're
trying to build out
uh
and but but the idea is what what can we
do to
to do that all kinds of things like
peter's got in his book of all kinds of
options as well as what i'm is what i'm
offering here today
yeah so i like this idea of conversation
starters i think we're putting a link to
them in the uh in the chat for folks
that are are following along
can you give us some examples what are
some examples of what these are and how
do they work yeah yeah so and and uh and
and you know i sometimes
the idea like with uh with fractions you
know i might come out and we might start
with a question like what what where's a
fraction you know and then and then well
the next question might be well is a
fraction one number or two numbers
and just sit back and talk about it talk
talk about what you think on that right
and uh and then well what do you think
of when you think of 3 8
okay what do you think of when you see
eight thirds
you know because if you're thinking of
three eighths as three out of eight then
eight thirds becomes something that's
maybe a little a little tougher to think
about
another example would be a question that
starts off with like well
what does division do for us
and so you want to sit back and you
think about what does division do for us
and then the next question would be not
not to do a division problem but to ask
a question like
how do you how can you think about with
outcome without computing how can you
think about a problem like 10 divided by
one half
and to be able to to be able to uh go on
to the next one well then how would you
think about
negative 10 divided by one half
right and if you're if your ways of
thinking are consistent and and uh
robust then you'll be able to your
answers were sort of gel together but if
you have fractures and if they're if
they're disjoint
then you kind of have to go back and
kind of try to figure out well how do i
get the i know that my thinking should
gel together with my answers to all of
these things
how what do i need to do how do i need
to accommodate the way i'm thinking in
order to make these things work from the
teacher's perspective we help provide
what you might be listening for in these
businesses
yeah
what are the things that you're looking
for from the teacher's perspective yeah
like so like we know we know
that we want fractions we want students
to be able to think of a fraction as
as a single number as a as a point on
the number line
right but if i'm talking about if i'm if
you know i ask my students about
fractions and they're saying well we're
only thinking of it as two numbers
then i'm talking about something as the
teacher that's completely different from
what they're hearing
and so it's this idea of getting these
meanings out in the open so that we all
know that we're talking about the same
thing so when i say fraction you're
thinking the same thing or when i talk
about division you've got a notion of
thinking of it as a as a multiplicative
comparison or you've got ways of
thinking about it in terms of how many
copies of one thing are in another or
this thing is this times as large as
this thing
right which when you have those ways of
thinking that a question like how can
you think of 10 divided by one half
doesn't become something that's out of
bounds at all it becomes something that
you can already hang under one of those
previous existing meanings of division
if they're if they're there if you've
got those ways of thinking
right right
yeah that makes sense so do these
starters work
across ages and grade levels are there
are there things that we need to be what
kinds of things can younger kids do and
what kinds of things can older kids
start to get
so the the interesting thing about them
is the way the way if you go down and
maybe some people have already gone and
downloaded the documents just while
we're sitting here but you'll see the
entry point the entry point into this is
through an item it's through a standard
but the idea is we've spent so many
years
uh unpacking standards digging in and
saying let's look at this one standard
what we want to do is say we're only
using this as the entry point because
what we want to do is we want to find
out what is all of the other mathematics
that has to come in alongside it
to help get through this we tend to we
tend to look at an item go this is the
standard and then we say well if they
get it wrong then we want to go back and
go to that nearest connecting standard
what we're saying here is actually maybe
you want to go ask them about what's a
fraction
right
right so let's go let's go talk about
what a fraction is it might not be the
nearest neighbor standard that's that's
the issue it could be some ways of
thinking that endure and that goes back
to your question about the you know who
are these four well
you can take the ones that we've got
packaged in the third grade and ask them
to seventh and eighth graders because
the ways of thinking are enduring
right and so the ideas are yes they grow
a little bit but they endure and they
grew out of these things actually grew
out of uh our thinking about what could
we help to provide
teachers with as we move into this phase
now where students are coming with such
uneven opportunities to learn
and philosophically i say well i can't
just be focused on ways of doing i have
to be focusing some way on the ways of
thinking and these habits of thinking
that come alongside it and so what what
could we do that's that's where we ended
up with this so if you are if you are
a third grade teacher you could probably
pull stuff from the fourth and fifth
grade if you're a high school teacher
you can pull things from any grades
right and they'll still be those to
still be fair game because they're
things to talk about ideas that endure
that go on and on so if you're in high
school you might dig into the functions
you might dig into comparison you might
dig into operations i hope you dig into
proportional relationships
yeah yes yes
so this whole conversation is making me
think about something that we talked a
lot about at khan academy which is what
sal used to call swiss cheese gaps but
now everyone calls unfinished learning
which is the idea that lots of folks
didn't get some of those foundational
concepts and when they were first
presented um and so try to then build
the next level without those concepts
which is kind of a shaky foundation and
it just keeps going
um so it sounds like these these
conversation starters are starting to
think about almost
diagnosing in some ways like do you have
those
those do you have these ways of thinking
right yeah the foundational ways of
thinking
which are you know when you look at your
state standards you're going to you're
going to see them kind of in there but
you might not see them as explicit as
we're trying to call them out here like
these are some core ones that you want
to keep coming back to you want to keep
revisiting these
and uh and keep listening and so the
kinds of questions that we are putting
out here use them however you want to
use them use them full class use them
one on one use them in small groups use
them for turning talks
the idea is the idea is to sit back and
listen
and it's also that what we would point
out is it's also not
it's not intended to
it's not it's
there will be a teachable moment it's
not during this time because we want to
set up the culture in such a way that
this is a this is free
open up okay tell me what you're
thinking and it's not the correct
it's the list and what's interesting
about that right is if you keep asking
more questions you might realize that
your first thoughts about their what
people like to call misconceptions could
be completely wrong that
you've misconceived their misconceptions
i don't like using the word
misconceptions because i yeah
the students have the conceptions and
this is all about what conceptions might
they have
right not what don't they have what
conceptions might they have how are they
thinking about these things and let's
and let's build from that that connects
back very closely to sal's uh house
house building analogy
yeah right right right these are these
these foundational they're more like
it's more like these foundational
threads that wind their way all the way
through not just right not just on the
bottom floor
yeah you just you just keep you just
strengthen them like the trunk of a tree
right it just keeps getting stronger and
stronger
yeah yeah absolutely that totally makes
sense
how do you think about the idea of
mastery in this in this world we talk a
lot about mastery learning here and you
know thinking it's easy when you're
talking about skills and having mastery
of skills but mastery of you know some
of these things is somewhat different is
that even a valid concept i don't know
yeah it's it's so hard to say what what
is mastery i mean we always want to draw
every right we always want to draw a
line for proficiency somewhere right
what it means to it right to have
learned something but in this in this
mindset you know on the ways of thinking
it's like these are things that continue
to grow and change morph and evolve and
and as as i think about well
how how how do we ever establish whether
students have mastered this i'm not sure
that that's even the right type of
question yeah rather than just like you
know it's just to keep on how is that
scheme how's that schema building up in
their minds as they as they continue to
go and and how can i how can i leverage
that to go on to that next place
right right you can think about how you
would expect some of these answers to
change as you learn new things
you're changing your ideas about what
these are as you kind of move up through
new skills and things are developing
interesting
so we obviously do a lot with technology
but we also want to think about how
teachers and technology work together
and so i'm interested in your thoughts
about you know the the interplay between
the two as i think about what you're
talking about things technology is never
going to be good at doing what you're
talking about
that's like the thing that teachers need
to be in classrooms so
i'm interested in your thoughts about
the how teachers and technology can work
together to build them
and that's and that's where yeah so i'm
i'm i'm i'm happy to hear you see it
that way because that's how i see it
right
it's that idea that uh
that
the compute computers they're they're
really good at helping with that way of
doing things right the way that but
but to sort of put these put these
complex ways of thinking together i mean
that takes some time and working and
developing and
and you know i just i just
to me i see a very human side to that
that uh yeah that would be very that
would be very hard to capture with that
with a computer system so uh each each
can play a very important role right uh
so so the
computers uh provide
provide an unfor
uh
un heretofore seen
access to
content in ways that we've never seen
before
right and so building that up but that
next task is well how do we how do we
take that access that that we've now
shared but how do we build in these
kinds of things can we what what can we
have the computers help to support us
with when it comes to engaging in these
kinds of conversations that will that
will be able to help sort of listen to
students and figure out exactly
sort of what might the next move be
based on ways of thinking not
necessarily just the ways of doing as
you might see pointed out in standards
and standards mappings that kind of
thing
yeah absolutely
so another piece that we try to
encourage is helping students become
owners of their own learning and
thinking about developing those
metacognitive skills being able to
understand what they know and evaluate
what they understand and need to learn
and how those fit in
um i'm interested in how you think about
that in some of this framework too
yeah well that that that might land in
that habits space right being able to
reflect on is being honest with myself
am i am i making sense am i in in my own
mind can i can i justify what i'm saying
can i put
or am i just starting off spouting
spouting things off uh
so so maybe maybe part of that is that
you can
with with with
this type of approach you you really do
get the opportunity for the student to
reflect it's by not correcting right
away by continuing to ask questions
you're providing the student
opportunities to reflect and then maybe
it may be when it's done and and you
know then you said you you sit down with
the student
and then you help them have some
metacognitive reflection on it what what
would you like to work on or what what
questions did you answer that you felt
like you wanted to take back or think
through again or think more about or
learn more about right to help them to
help them spot where they they need ways
they wanted to strengthen their ways of
thinking
yeah that makes sense i think that idea
of helping um of
thinking about
um
your confidence in your answers is
something that we talk about too like
after students give answers having them
think about so how sure of you were that
answer and what did you know and didn't
you know
and i could see them doing it with this
too so asking students what do you you
know what do you think a fraction is and
then
how comfortable are you in that answer
and where that fits in would be
interesting yeah yeah to think about
yeah definitely
so i what um as you think about advising
teachers on next steps so they've had
this conversation what is the next thing
they should do based on the information
that they get
well i think as you're listening you're
trying to you're trying to interpret
right
what are you noticing what work on work
on those what what do you want to notice
with what the with what the student's
saying uh reflect back on it if you
some of them we in our in this
the things that we're putting together
around these we've got some videos and
it's very fun to it's very fun to to sit
and watch uh because you kind of get to
if you watch it two or three times
sometimes you'll get even more and more
out of it uh so it's kind of a you know
yeah teachers what
what what could you do with these
what
you know i don't know did i get that
answer that okay all right yeah so the
idea it's going to have the teachers are
going to have to do some
um pretty
good interpretation of what they're
hearing and then think about based on
that what are the
understandings that they need to
either fill in or move forward or what
that what that looks like
and and
and it's also it's also
self-reflective i mean when we when we
were putting these they made all of us
stop and think
we had to sit there and think oh how
would we answer
this yeah because it was
basically it wasn't we weren't we
weren't putting questions down to get
right or wrong answers it's coming up
with questions that uncover thinking
and you don't have to ask right or wrong
questions to uncover thinking
right right yeah
that's
i think that's another piece in math
math education that we're coming to
better understandings of that math
education isn't just about writing wrong
answers and
where things are math does have right
and wrong answers to some things but not
minimizing it i'm not minimizing the
need for right or wrong answers right
but there's a time for that and there's
a time for
listening to thinking
yeah yeah that's really makes sense
excellent
um so anything that you're excited about
i'll close on this question anything
you're excited about in the coming
couple of months that your teamwork is
working on
oh
oh yeah
yeah the uh
so one of one of the things i'm working
on i just i just did a talk on this at
south by southwest last week and it's
called i called it mathematical rigor
mortis the quest for a cure
and it's this and it's this idea where
when we sit back and we think about our
field math teachers we think about how
many ways does math kill things right
math kills dreams it kills joy it kills
progress
and and i think and also it also kills
it also kills moving policy in the right
directions and and and making changes at
systemic levels it's these things are so
entrenched in the way that we do things
but i'm encouraged and i'm encouraged
and i hope i hope that the the folks out
there encourage that i think i think
we're moving in the right direction to
cure mathematical rigor mortis and uh
and if you want to if you ever want to
reach out and talk to me about it i'd
love to i'd love to
go into that as well but that's
something i'm encouraged about is the
the sort of spaces on the things i'm
seeing across the country to help
address that and we had a question from
angel on youtube who's a student and
wants to know
how they can stay motivated when they're
doing work we hear this a question a lot
from folks who are needing to say stay
motivated to do their work what do you
think
oh
you know so so
maybe maybe angel uh and i hope this
this is helpful but
if if math is being presented to you as
though it's the collection of puzzle
pieces that you're just shaking the box
and you can kind of hear them rattling
uh the challenge the challenge would be
to know that it does make a big
beautiful picture that all of the pieces
fit together that no piece stands alone
and that and that if if you find that
encouraging then then you can figure out
how these pieces fit together how what's
the story that's being told here it's a
great one uh and uh and there are lots
of places where you could go to help get
some support on that as well but don't
don't let don't let
the the current situations that you
might be in or these
you know these things that are happening
all around us right now don't let them
destroy the joy that mathematics has for
you that would that would be my take so
i like it and putting together that
puzzle could be a challenge a fun
challenge to undertake and to think
through excellent yeah but it's there
it's ready to be put together but it
gets put together in your own head
so fantastic well thank you so much for
joining us today it was a pleasure to
talk to you and i hope some of our our
folks out there dive into those
conversation starters well thank you
this is great